what is the book that you've gifted the
most a nerd in shining armor that's just
a book about someone who was nerdy who
you wouldn't think would be cool and he
ends up being cool and he actually saved
someone's life so there's a boat that I
give to co-workers cuz I work with
special needs students it's called ten
things your autistic child wishes that
you knew it's really helpful I just read
this book as like as a project for
English and that was called me and Earl
and the dying girl and it was so good
like he just cuz I'm in high school and
the book is about a high schooler and
like I can like connect to the
characters so much because we're both
like at the same age so it was like
really nice to see that I actually had a
friend and I told him to read it and
then once he did he already liked in
class and you just burst into laughter
sometimes because he thought that it was
so funny so if you want to laugh it's a
good book to read
ooh man Christ and a Bible I guess
everybody need some help now and again
some guidance you know I've never gifted
a book but if I would would beat the
elegance of the Hedgehog why that one
it caused me to have an existential
crisis and I think that everyone
deserves to have an existential crisis
what's it about it's about a landlady
who is an apartment in France and
everyone in her apartment is super rich
and like they just don't get it and she
gets it and it's all about people in the
world who need to get it and I think
that's something good everyone needs to
do so I I think yeah everyone needs to
read it absolutely I would say the book
that I'd get to the most is this book
called where chefs eat
I try to describe it okay so it's
exactly what it sounds like we're chefs
globally it's their favorite places
throughout there is countries and cities
and you know big and small it's just a
favorite spots whether it's like the
place they go to after work or the place
where they really want to get really
fancy and taste like some new stuff that
will inspire them have you visited a lot
of this bug that they talked about in
the back yes I have and I have a lot of
friends that have met along the way and
so usually when I go to a new place I
like ask them like have you ever been
here cuz I always look at the book
before I go somewhere and
I've been to a few of them and it's
crazy that they've always been good it's
never let me down
Great Expectations because it teaches
basically that in life you don't need
monetary things to succeed
you just need good morals and good
values lullaby by Chuck Palahniuk
the book is just so moving is about a
model who distorts her face and chance
to find yourself again not by I don't
have to say her name like the name is
like Kay and OTS like Donald yeah I
don't have not selfish name but it's
just a collection of short stories I
really like it okay why do you think you
give that to the bugs oh it's so weird I
don't know I like giving it to people so
they can have that weird experience
white people you meet in heaven
one because it's a really good book I
like that I read it and I love this or
that's the one that I choose
give no
Oh Huckleberry Finn
I've been gifted that and have both
gifted that because I read it not for
school like a pleasure like later on and
I thought I was wonderful is such a good
story it's just a lot of good stuff so
it's probably yeah
I think that would be it so essentially
it's about Huckleberry Finn who escapes
his abusive father by pretending by
faking his own death and then lives on
an island with one of his friends was
also slave and it does take place during
this time it's really rough there's a
lot of life you know
interpersonal relationships that are
like really interesting to think but
also just it's a whole different writing
style I feel like I realized
contemporary stuff and while it's just
for the story and I don't know I just
enjoyed it a lot and I think it's
definitely a book worth reading nowadays
my answer is sister outsider which is a
collection of Audrey Lorde poems and
why do you think you get this often it's
kind of like one of those movies where
every single time you watch it you get
something different from it so many of
the essays in particular an essay called
the transformation of silence through
language in action I read it I try to
read at least like five times a year and
every single time I read it I find
something new and amazing and
eye-opening and just like a gem that's
in there and helps me sort of reframe my
mindset and my view of my own life
recently it's called letting go pathway
to surrender but I think it's David
Hawkins something like that but if you
look up the title you'll find it the
reason why is because it really teaches
about how to be more self-aware when it
comes to your own emotions
and how things in the past or traumas in
the past holding onto them doesn't
actually serve you from
achieving what you want and my
the book I probably give the most is
traveling with your pet for California
so for people who want to go find places
to live
sleep and eat and what campgrounds allow
pets with national parks allow pets and
hotels and restaurants all along the
coast well it's probably children's
books because I have lots of nieces and
nephews so
probably the most is that that
children's book the mitten because it
has beautiful illustrations and I think
kids really respond to the artwork and I
want kids to love art a man named O and
which was a really good book so I I
think I would recommend that because it
was lost my read what was it about it's
about an old man that is trying to
commit suicide that he keeps getting and
interrupted every time he tries and he
figures out that the reason why he
hasn't finished is because there's so
many people that need his help and it
just turns into there's so many people
that need his help they he just quits
trying I just read this book Fahrenheit
451 it shows you not to get too caught
up in technology and spend time
socializing with others and really
appreciate what we have it shows you to
also share your opinion and that your
opinion support important
yeah it's a great book everybody should
read it it teaches you a lot of great
lessons I would have to say freakonomics
it's a book about like these really
interesting
like hearing about you
why sumo wrestlers Chi and like why
people are called the way they're called
like destiny
actually it's kind of interesting
I'd say unashamed by the break
it's a book just because I mean to me
out resonating with a lot and I just
feel it brings a boost a nice message
that people good listen to so about said
it's who have referred it to a couple of
homies in - off like that far as the
only book that I really read extensively
over
because why good about basically so he's
a he's a he's a rapper you know and he's
actually pretty strong in his in his
faith believing it in Christ and stuff
like that so he's just pretty much this
whole this whole life story in his
testimony just how is how he's changed
you know
and the president how he's going and
involved in any much a shuttle make any
impact in the world
it's called a liar's this book gets a
bow long there's no such thing as a
talent or a gift its amount of time and
dedication and you being worn the right
place that would get you to where you
will end up a lot to succeed Oh Tim
Ferriss loves to ask that question in
his podcast the book that I've gifted
the most is the book that I give at baby
showers it's like 12 weeks to sleep it's
how to teach your baby to fall asleep
really quickly why do you think you give
that
cuz I've heard it works very well I've
never had a baby so I don't know but
that's what the mothers have told me is
actually the reason why
No yeah I look the other thing I love is
my cousin what's up guys my name is
Mariah and I'm the owner of this channel
I'm also the person behind the camera
and I thought I'd take a minute to thank
all the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask the new year's to hit the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're a fan of my channel
in general a lot thank you